the eu has agreed to cut its emissions
by 55
by 2030. the european parliament wanted
60 so have you settled for two smaller
cuts
well i think we've we've found a way out
that would
allow council to agree with it and
parliament to see that it
got a lot out of these negotiations
because now we can also
operate with a so-called carbon budget
which will make it clearer how much
we're using up of the room we have
we have more clarity on our trajectory
to 2040
and 2050 who will have a greater
influence of scientific evidence in our
decision making
and that's all thanks to the negotiating
powers of parliament so
i think at the end of the day everybody
was very happy with the result
and yet some would say that 55 doesn't
go far enough
independent scientific analysts climate
action tracker for example says the eu
would need to set a target of
65 percent not 55 percent and fund
climate action abroad in order to have
commitments that are compatible with the
paris agreement
well i i do disagree um i think with
the target we've set which is at least
55
percent and all the measures we're
taking we did a very profound
impact uh analysis uh and i think this
takes us on a trajectory to climate
neutrality
uh by uh 2050 and i have to
i have to tell you that apart from the
uk there's nobody else
on the planet that is doing as much as
the eu is doing
so in that sense i believe we're we're
together with the uk
we're setting a trend and now others are
following like united states and
hopefully also
other big emitters such as china will
follow a suit
and i believe if you put all these
efforts together
we could we could really get to climate
neutrality by the middle of the century
and i think
i think um we need to start immediately
and
uh what we've done with the climate law
compels the european union to stick
to that trajectory and i i believe uh
this is is
is what needs to be done also by other
major emitters
you referenced the uk there your target
does trail behind the uk's doesn't it
they've announced a target of 68
reduction by 2030
78 by 2035. what do you make of their
targets
well i think it's a very good target
it's it's a bit apples and oranges you
can't really compare all these targets
but
the uk is ahead of the rest of the world
i hope this will also translate
into concrete measures that's what we're
doing we we've
we're going to present to the european
parliament and to the council of
ministers
a package of measures that would for
instance
enhance our emissions trading system
would speed up
our transition to renewable energy would
really speed up
our transition to electric mobility etc
etc
so i hope the uk will back up its pledge
also with policies and i
i really look forward to working
together with the uk
on this and you know at the end of the
day frankly i don't care who wins
i mean everybody wins and if the uk is
ahead of the eu
good for them but we'll see each other
in 2050 and hopefully
both we will reach climate neutrality by
then and you talk about that transition
to renewable energy
for some countries in the eu that's
going to be a real challenge
isn't it i'm thinking particularly of
poland we reported from there yesterday
and we could see that they depend on
coal for around
75 percent of their electricity so what
does the eu
have to do to make that transition for
them easier how much money are they
going to have to spend on poland
well first of all i think i think
everybody now knows that there's no
future in coal
and nobody knows that better than people
in poland because
they see what's happening in the markets
they see that there's no one
who wants to invest in that they're left
with all this coal they're digging up
and nobody's buying it so they know
something needs to change
and we will show solidarity at eu level
we will have
a just transition fund we will see also
now in the recovery period
uh a lot of money going to poland to
restructure its
economy we're talking about uh more than
one quarter of polish gdp that it will
get in support
from the european union and i think
there is there are so many benefits in
this because
you know you will create new jobs uh for
people who are now working in the coal
mining industry there are huge
opportunities poland is a country with a
tremendous amount of engineers and we
will be needing engineers in this
economy that's coming with hydrogen with
the circular economy
and all these new technologies that will
be applied and these are huge
opportunities
but of course the transition is going to
be extremely complicated for everyone
this is going to be very very
complicated time ahead of us
but the alternative doing nothing is
going to create many more problems than
actually acting well yes and it's
interesting you say that it's going to
be very complicated for everyone because
you've actually said before haven't you
that decarbonization
needs a tectonic shift in the way
society is structured
do you think that national politicians
are being honest enough
with their people about how their lives
are going to change and how soon
well you know i i've been in politics
for over 30 years i've
i've been a national politician been
elected to my national parliament for
six
six times so so i have some experience
and and it's always difficult
uh to confront uh your electorate with
very very difficult messages
especially you know we're in a pandemic
we people are suffering so much and then
you have to tell them
by the way we have a couple of other
crises that are actually
life-threatening that we need to address
um but i think we ca we can't afford the
luxury
of not telling the truth um you know i i
don't want to
to to see my children and my children's
children asking themselves
well our grandparents knew this was
happening why didn't they act
we can't afford to do that and honestly
i believe that
you know we're also in an industrial
revolution these changes are tectonic
and we need to shape them this is the
time for politics this is a time
that society needs to take its own
destiny its own hands
if we just let it happen then the happy
few will come out
stronger and and the large majority of
the population
will suffer if we if we shape it if we
take
initiatives if we change our society
into a sustainable way
that we can make sure that we leave no
one behind i think that that's the
that's the huge task we we
face but it's feasible it is feasible
so what do those changes look like for
individuals
how will their lives change because
obviously some jobs are going to go
aren't they i mean people might
be encouraged to get around very
differently they might be encouraged to
eat very differently
what do you think those changes look
like for individuals
well our lives will change whether we
adapt to climate change or we don't
because if we don't and climate change
the temperature will go
above uh two degrees in increase
and then uh you know the weather
patterns will be more erratic
we will have more firestorms we'll have
more droughts etc
and that will have a huge impact on our
lives if we let that happen
our children will fight wars over water
and food
so we need to change but the change
doesn't have to be
ah doesn't have to take away the value
of our life it will increase the value
of our life
when we change when we change the way we
move around when we
when we eliminate uh combustion engines
and go to electric vehicles
we will have cleaner air in in in our
cities
we will have more safety on our roads uh
when we change the way we eat and we're
more conscious of what we eat
we will reduce the risk of of ecocide of
biodiversity
um disappearing when we go to a circular
economy
we will reduce massively our waste and
we will do something about what david
attenborough has been teaching us
from the beginning and that is taking
away all this plastic waste
out of the oceans if we don't change
there will be more plastic in the oceans
than fish
50 years from now so the changes is a
positive change
of course it will be difficult bloody
difficult honestly speaking
it would be very difficult but just i i
just don't want
people to un to to underestimate the
negative consequences of not acting
uh and i believe that uh acting will
take us to a society
that we can we can truthfully hand over
to our children and grandchildren in a
good conscience
uh saying that we set the uh a world
on a track that will allow humanity to
live within the boundaries of the planet
we've never learned to live within the
boundaries of the planet we need to
learn it now